It recommends picking a major or
primary color that is representative
of your app's branding or personality.
You can use this color in large
blocks such as this toolbar
to make your app instantly recognizable.
For example,
YouTube's primary color would be red or
inbox's color would be blue.
Next, you pick an accent color.
This is a brighter, more saturated color
designed to draw attention to certain
elements, such as
a floating action button.
Two colors alone may not be enough
range to create your whole UI, so
we then break these down into lightness
ranges to build out your palette.
Here's an example of Material's
light blue color swatch.
Material assigns numerical
values to this range,
where lighter shades have a lower number
and darker shades have a higher number.
These numbers themselves don't mean
anything intrinsically, but they're
useful terminology when discussing
when to use a particular tint.
We calibrate our lightness scale on your
primary color calling it the 500 shade.
Then darker shades have higher numbers,
like 700 or 900.
And lighter shades have lower numbers.
We use an A prefix for those accent,
those more saturated colors
that we talked about.
Such as, light blue A200.
Now we recommend that you stick
to three hues of your primary and
one accent color to keep your
palette simple, but versatile.
For example,
let's create the palette for
an app which has an indigo personality.
I'll pick indigo 500 shade
as my primary color.
And then grab the indigo 700 and
300 shades for complementary areas.
Next, I'll pick pink A200 as a hot
accent color for contrasting elements.
Let's apply our shiny
new palette to our app.
We can use the primary color in blocks
of your UI like extended toolbars,
to embed our personality.
Next, we could apply the 700
shade to the status bar to give
it contrast against the toolbar.
And then the 300 shade for a block of
secondary information for example.
Finally, we'll use the accent color
on elements you want call out,
such as the fab, on toggles or
perhaps a focused text field.
Material provides a hand-tuned pallet of
colors that you can use in your apps,
and are a great starting point if
you don't have an existing brand.
If you do, however, then you absolutely
should use your own brand colors.
But, applying the Material
system of accents and
shades helps to work this into your UI.
If you have a primary color, but
no accent, then you can use color fairy,
such as complimentary colors
to help you pick one.
There's some great tools online.
This is an example from color.adobe.com.
If you really want a monochromatic
palate, so just one color in there,
it's fine to just use just
shades of your primary color.
But then you're going to lose the
ability to highlight certain elements.
A quick tip is that you'll likely
use your accent color close to or
on top of your primary color.
So, for example,
the fab on top of this toolbar here.
So you want to make sure you pick
colors that have enough contrast.
So this one would get a little bit lost.
So that's the essence of working
with color in Material Design.
This is the most powerful, immersive and
completely adaptable
to your application.
So no matter if your app is whimsical or
serious, it's easy to work
with color to express that.